c'est catastrophique là
utiliser la nature comme une alliée dans
cette prise de décision le pouvoir
d'intervention d'une ville est
extrêmement limitée on a perdu cette
infrastructure là en cinq six ans
seulement
les rivages calme du Saint-Laurent dans
le sud du Québec peuvent avoir un tout
autre visage
mais ce qui frappe surtout c'est la
défiguration des berges et cette
résidence de Berchères se sont
impuissante on voit là que c'est
complètement tombé le muret ici est en
porte-à-faux
le gouvernement fédéral des murets pour
protéger les berges lors de l'ouverture
de la voie maritime mais Ottawa les a
abandonnés à la fin des années 90 c'est
celui-là qui est de la voisine qui est
en train de tomber complètement on voit
les grandes plaques de béton qui tombent
ça c'est pas les miennes les miennes
sont déjà partis dans le fleuve ça vient
gruger la tarte de plus en plus alors ça
recule et ça recule et c'est
catastrophique c'est tellement désolant
le problème est le même de chaque côté
du fleuve là où la voie maritime était
étroite comme entre Montréal et le lac
Saint-Pierre
une érosion causée en grande partie par
les navires de plus en plus imposants
qui vogue à quelques dizaines de mètres
des berges les bords du parc de la
commune à Varennes en témoignent de
façon un peu plus criante chaque année
ajouter au moins 10 mètres 30 à 40 pieds
c'est là où il y a à peu près 10 ans on
était regardé aujourd'hui on perd un
mètre par année il y a ce bon sur le
point de basculer alors qu'il a été
installé à bonne distance du rivage il y
a 5 ans
ou encore la piste cyclable qui bordent
le parc sauvé in extremis l'année
dernière par un aménagement au frais de
la ville à la tête de l'Union des
municipalités du Québec Martin danfouz
réclame un pacte vert un financement
récurrent de 2 milliards de dollars pour
aider les villes à s'adapter aux
changements climatiques qui jouent aussi
un rôle dans l'érosion qui a serré main
trois facteurs clairement bien
identifiés le passage des bateaux bien
sûr que le bâti âge la grosseur des
bateaux la vague est plus importante le
rosement des niveaux de la mer avec la
fonte des glaces fait en sorte que l'eau
est en plus haute bien frappé plus haut
sur les terres mais le troisième facteur
puisqu'on a des hivers moins glacés
avant le bar des rives du fleuve à
Varennes a toujours été glacé dur dur
dur donc il y avait pas de mouvement de
glace qui venait frapper sur le long des
berges donc multiplier ces trois
facteurs là on est pris avec une
accélération de l'érosion des mais
comment intervenir pour freiner le
phénomène dans le sud du Québec la
vieille méthode de l'enrochement ou du
muret de béton a des limites et pas
seulement esthétiques il y a une
certaine interaction qui se produit avec
le courant de dérive finalement la
décharge du fleuve Saint-Laurent et
parfois ça permet de transmettre le
problème au voisin quand on essaie de
lutter contre les éléments ça ne fait
pas partie des bonnes pratiques de
stabiliser les berges d'un bout à
l'autre il faut travailler avec ces
services écosystémiques de régulation à
l'Institut national de la recherche
scientifique le professeur jacobstolleu
teste justement un nouveau dispositif
dans un grand canal à vague son équipe
mesure l'effet de dispersion d'un
brise-lames qui sera végétalisé on
essaie cette année de mise en place
notre première prototype de ce type
flottant pour protéger pour continuer
l'énergie des vagues donc on a fait des
tests à plus petit à échelle et on voit
des
un projet pilote financé en partie par
le port de Montréal mais sur le long
terme qui devra payer c'est la question
que le maire de lanoray est allé poser à
un comité des communes à la fin de
l'année dernière
on s'est développé économiquement et de
belles façons grâce à la voix maritime
et que il y a un pourcentage des
dommages actuellement des préjugés aux
citoyens qui sont dus à la navigation
maritime comme collectivité je pense
qu'on doit on doit intervenir la balle
est désormais dans le camp d'Ottawa un
rapport sur l'érosion a été présenté à
la Chambre des communes fin avril ne
reste plus qu'à attendre la réponse du
gouvernement avec son comité de
protection Micheline Lagarde pense aussi
que c'est au fédéral d'investir pour les
générations futures
si le fleuve c'est un joyau les berges
c'est son écran puis il faut en prendre
soin aussi